against the braves left-hander who has
struggled in his career against the
nationals bj hopefully today is one of
the days for max that he can turn those
gaudy numbers around yeah he's going in
the right direction fast boss curveball
type pitcher he gets ahead with that
fastball but hey against washington
watson is hitting 271 versus left-hand
pitches that leads to national league so
he's going to have to get ahead and that
curveball has to be effective today
and freed turns it loose and a good live
fastball struck him out
a one pitch
little roller out to short dansby's on
the other end he gathers perfectly
throws over to austin reilly two down a
two-out double by zimmerman
and the breaking ball got it to swing
and miss booking strikeouts for max free
good start for the braves lefty 15 games
13 starts corbin career against the
braves
last start august 3rd against the
phillies took the 5-4 loss gave up four
runs on six hits over seven innings
struck out eight phillies 93 pitches 66
for strikes opponent hits just 191
against
the patrick corbin slider
down and in
patrick corbin getting ahead and then
burying the breaking ball
breaking ball away
and solera got it down around the end of
the bat so an easy fly ball yaddiel
hernandez
two down
corbin delivers fastball line to left
coming in is yadiel and hernandez makes
the catch for the out
good play coming straight in on a line
drive to left on the first pitch of the
advancement
which all the way to kibum that's a
little shot out the eight a's got it at
third goes to ozzy at second for one oh
but o'reilly double play
five four three they send it around the
horn
3-1 pitch popped up on the infield
in foul territory a trio of braves there
and ana takes control at the last moment
and makes the catch there's a moment of
hesitation there and confusion between
na
and kevin smith
small sample size
and on the shift that's the second
baseman garcia on the left side of
second
okay
i can't even look
slider in the dirt barrera will step out
into the throwing lane and patrick
corbin has his second strikeout remember
when bryce stepped on the eight it was a
big deal
back back back goes yadiel hernandez
handling his third play of the day
patrick is throwing strikes
popped in the air riley dives can't make
the play free though heads up gets the
out at second
did not panic he grabbed it and ozzy
being in the right position at the right
time at second base
wow what instincts by free too and now
you keep the double play in order
[Applause]
won the gold glove last year for a
reason guys
nice effort by riley
and escobar get a [ __ ] down and in and
out to center it's on the ground
garcia coming home the nets on top
and he got zimmerman to swing and miss
96 and throw him with a bit of anger
there
two outs runners at first and second one
nothing washington
high hopper hit towards short gansby's
got it goes the short way to second
close play
and that will retire the side alcides
escobar a soft run scoring hit max matt
about the walk to the pitcher as he
trails one nothing
and right there carter ki boom two down
i think he's laughing because he
probably didn't see that does he say oh
my goodness right there
this one on the ground and it's max free
that breaks up the perfect game
back to the top of the order now to ozzy
obviously guys can mix and match
that ball is well struck to center look
at it kerry robles to the wall hey it's
gone
well maybe he will stay in lead off
ozzy albee's just hit his 18th
and with a little help from max freed
atlanta has its first lead you're right
that's the keats a little help from max
free getting the base hit getting on
giving how's the albie's the opportunity
to hit with somebody on the base
and this is what we've been waiting for
from the lead-off ozzy albies
washington's out hit the braves 5-3 but
an all-bees home run the difference in
the game
as corbin off stride pops one into left
adam duvall will make that play
and there's the first out
as this one's hitting the air toward
left not deep
two outs
a hot day the pitch
is in the air to right solaire should
pull that in he does
and it's three out three down for max
freed his first perfect and clean inning
in a 2-1 lead
here comes the bottom of the fifth
[Music]
fly ball to victor this time
fooled
at first
and he catches it about
395 feet away
down and in
perfect pitch
in that count strikeout number five
a minute three and 12.
now the banner max freedom to tap her
right back to corbin he has it off the
first base silent jogging toward first a
short flip to ryan zimmerman and the
side retired so corbin with another
amazingly quick inning retires the
braves on six pitches
and hernandez waits for that breaking
ball
bell gets a read ball not hit hard he's
over to third base
yadiel hernandez wants to start a new
hitting streak he's two for three today
and now a big pitch the 2-2
hey
strzok came out after the meeting with
smith a couple of swings and misses
and kibum has struck out twice today two
outs first and third as barrera awaits
you one poked up the middle but right at
the bag ozzy will take it to the pillow
and that will retire the side a quick
meeting from kevin smith gets freed off
the hook in the sixth and he enjoys a
one-run lead
the 2-1
swinging a ground ball deep in the hole
at short backhand play escobar jump
throw to second they get the out as
garcia scoops the low throw nice play
ball cds escobar just to get one
in some serious range here got a nice
sunday hop on a sunday and then the
throw with the jump
to get the force out at second nice play
that's pretty
right there and a nice pick by luis
garcia on the back end
austin 0-4-2 today
one ball one strike
this one down the right-field line that
might turn to gold it is a fair ball
swanson around third they're going to
wave him they miss the cut-off man and
the braves get a gift
but another guy out there for duvall who
singled his last time he's starting to
relax a little bit smoke to deep left
two-run homework for duvall into the hey
garrett
a line drive missile good call bj
i'll tell you guys
you go the other way all of a sudden you
start feeling comfortable
five straight strikeouts
[Applause]
on the play garcia goes to third with
one out
guys are ripping and that's out to left
center
victor robles first knock of the day
garcia touches home
for the second nat's run he also had the
first one
zimmerman laces one to right center
and because he got to second on the wild
pitch victor robles scores
the nats are
back in the game it's five to three
juan soto will be pigeoning for tres
pereira soto's 0 for two of the
strikeout against richard the pitch
perfect pitch
when soto goes back and looks at the
tape of this one
he has no argument that is a strike
good call
one out away escobar has been a pest
first pit swing fly ball well hit duval
sprinting to the edge of the track that
ball carrying out to the wall he leaps
he had it and dropped it
and escobar is in at second base oh
duvall had it in the glove could not
hang on and the nationals are still
alive
ryan zimmerman's two for four
zimmerman
serves one left center that ball's on
the ground escobar is going to score
it is a three-hit day for ryan zimmerman
his second driven in with the scrappy
gnats down just to run
[Applause]
on the ground ozzy's got it thrown at
first and the braves have won the series
the nats gave the braves everything they
could want in a three-game set fellas
this was a hard earned series victory
and now we get a day off we're in second
place and we've got the cincinnati reds
tuesday night